Jerry says, if you do not, if you do comment on quote, not so
niche relevant websites, but with good metrics, can it somehow
backfire and make uncle Google confused about what topic your
website really is about? What are your thoughts on that,
Eugene?
I mean, like, like I said, you know, we're, we're really, we're
really at a very, no, I wouldn't, I wouldn't say that.
No, I mean, I think Google is smart enough at this point to
know like what your content is. And, you know, I've seen like,
probably thousands of websites getting backlinks this kind of
like this way, right? So like, I don't, you know, I don't think
that's going to be issue. The only issue is, it's really just
going to be like, it's not going to be as effective as if you can
get a relevant backlink from a good website, right? But, but
yeah, I mean, we do it all the time. And, you know, we don't
have any penalty problems or miss indexing problems or
anything like that.
I think it's more if you get the relevancy, it's going to help.
If you don't, it's not going to help, but it's not going to hurt
you, because I know how I would look at it.